ah Microsoft Windows the king of the PC
loved it or hated Windows is one of the
most profitable products ever made with
1.6 billion users so how did we get here
well our story starts in 1981 a small
software company called Microsoft hit it
big with a text-based operating system
called ms-dos for IBM's new personal
computers BES was efficient for the time
but the average computer user wanted
something more accessible so Microsoft
use an internal product called interface
manager to put a graphical face on DOS
get to 1985 and you've got Windows 1.0
this really is a great product it may
look crude but this first version of
Windows was pretty revolutionary it
brought us the things we know and love
to this day drop-down menus scroll bars
icons and dialog boxes it also used this
new device called a mouse to help users
practice their math skills version 1.1
included the game Reversi
in 1987 Windows 2.0 arrived with better
graphics including overlapping windows
one year later Microsoft became and
stayed the largest PC software maker in
the early 90s Microsoft sold tens of
millions of copies of windows 3.0 and
3.1 and say hello to procrastination
classic solitaire and minesweeper then
windows mania hit an all-time high in
1995 with Windows 95 Microsoft sold 7
million copies in the first five weeks
the Start menu arrived and so did lots
of bugs Windows 98 was essentially an
across-the-board upgrade but not
everyone was happy
your coldest window Sunday would be back
up it is faster over 5 million
y2k Microsoft put up Windows ME for home
which no one bought and a loaded up
Windows 2000 for business which boosted
sales with a pricier option the 2001
successor Windows XP was fast stable and
tuned for the Internet and media who was
a hit with consumers after six years of
awesome
Microsoft tried to write a brand new
Windows Vista ended up being a terrible
mess of glitches took Microsoft two
years to fix the mess it had made with
Windows 7 a product finally good enough
to convince most people to move from XP
in 2012 Microsoft tried to be radical
again with Windows 8 it did away with
the traditional desktop and replaced it
with piles which attempted to bridge PCs
laptops tablets and smartphones
most people were confused and went back
to the familiar desktop and what about
Windows 9 I don't know what about it
today we have Windows 10 it takes us
back to the familiar desktop and Start
menu and it's free this will also
probably be the last time Microsoft puts
a number on Windows going forward
Windows will just be Windows